you are in going to be in the upcoming
movie alien covenant yes yeah and what's
kind of cool about that I mean it's a
cool gig anyway but you were a big fan
of the alien movies which makes this an
even bigger deal how this all happened
it was a yeah it was incredible you know
like I've always been a fan of the films
and yeah I at the began to at the
beginning of I guess in the last year I
got a call that Ridley Scott wanted to
meet me and I had no idea what it was
for I'm a humongous fan of his he
directed the original alien and I went
into his office to meet with him and I
wasn't sure what it was about and about
halfway through the conversation he
starts showing me these sketches of
spaceships and aliens and I'm just like
oh my god this is about alien he's he's
brought me here about alien and when it
was over he didn't offer me the role or
anything it was just sort of like to
meet with me about it
and so I I didn't really know what it
was like I don't know if he just like
heard I was a fan he was testing out the
material to see if I thought it was cool
[Laughter]
that's a cool spaceship it's the moon
[Laughter]
I don't want you to give anything away
but the experience is shooting the movie
is it is it incredible it's incredible
it's also the very first time I've been
in a movie where people like died in it
so it's like you start the film at these
dinners with like humongous like a big
cast all these people are there and then
every week it's just like the table gets
smaller now you've always been a big
film buff you were film buff growing up
as a kid I was you know it's funny
enough even with uh with aliens it's
like we would go on Friday nights to the
video store things that don't exist
anymore right and uh and I would always
this is young like you know is akin
elementary school I would always go for
the rated-r films and I would just kind
of like slide them in the last minute my
parents were checking out and then what
I would do is I would get up very early
Saturday morning before they were up to
watch them write and and I actually did
that with aliens I got a very early
Saturday morning I put it on and then my
mom wakes up early he starts making
breakfast and she's there and I'm just
like this is not gonna fly and I lay and
see the screen you can see this pretty
but you can hear what's happening and uh
and at one point you look what is this
that you're watching you know they
cursed one more time this is going off
we're not gonna we're not gonna sit here
and listen to this and I'm like okay
yeah whatever and then Bill Paxton comes
on with that like epic monologue about
gameover gameover he drops the f-bomb
like 30 times and nito say it was like I
hadn't shut the movie off and I never
saw what happened to Newt or Ridley for
ten years yeah
you